there has been criticism of the sexual
violence in the books and perhaps more
so in the show and they're different and
that is historically accurate I mean war
treated women always has treated women
very very badly
yes rape has taken place in virtually
every war that ever happened and and not
just in ancient times although in
medieval times it was it was so endemic
it was almost except that is you know
that that was part of what happened in
war and if your town was taken then the
other army would rape all your women and
it continues to this day I mean there
the rape camps in Bosnia a few years ago
the the stuff that happened in world war
ii i mean it's it's there it's always
there you can't leave it out so it is
historically accurate but you've also
taken advantage of the possibilities of
fantasy by creating female characters
who couldn't have existed and who
warriors manipulative priestesses the
queen with dragons
well the Dragons certainly did not exist
although it should be pointed out I'll
get back to the main question a minute
but it should be pointed out that in the
real medieval times people believed in
dragons people believed in witches you
know so like we include a witch like
Noah Sondra and my books called the red
witch and she's a fantasy element but it
is we didn't have that in the real world
but the people living in that real world
thought they had it they executed women
because they thought they were witches
they hung them or they burned them or
they pressed them to death under large
stones and if you could bring one here
with a time machine I would say of
course we had witches what are you
talking about witches were real they
killed my cow with a spell they gave me
warts they you know had suckled the
devil every night under the dark of the
moon and they believed they were dragons
out there they believed they were
manticores and if you believe something
enough it becomes part of your world and
it affects the way you live your
- it affects the decisions you make and
you know getting back to the issue yeah
I've I've added dragons I've added some
fantasy elements some magic and all that
but I don't think the women are magical
yeah but it to be historically accurate
would be to limit your character
development it's more fun to move into
fantasy with women I don't think I have
moved into fantasy with women aside from
Danish dragons I think you can find you
can find an analog for every one of the
women in my in my books
yeah that's their unusual they're the
exception they're not the rule you know
but the exception is what you want to
write about you don't necessarily want
to write about the typical example the
typical knight or the typical king or
peasant it's it's the ones who are a
little more complicated than that they
give you a little more juice to write
about you know what what didn't happen
where I think some of my fellow
fantasies move into fantasy is and with
their depictions of the the class system
there's a my books were at least partly
written as an answer to what I call the
Disneyland fantasies out there where
writers who toki and imitators chiefly
who love the having the princesses and
the knights and the castles and all that
so they put all of that in but they
don't really seem to realize what I grew
out of they'd like the class distinction
so you you always get the scene with a
spunky peasant girl tells off the you
know the arrogant Lord the spunky
peasant girl who told off a real
arrogant Lord and and like 12:23 would
have had her head chopped off or at
least her tongue ripped out
you know these social systems had teeth
you can't just take 21st century
Americans and and put them in surcoats
and and mantels and give them a sword
and pretend that they're medieval people
medieval way of thinking was quite
different you mentioned beliefs religion
is a thread that that flows through here
what is it about faith that attracts you
religion has paid a huge part in human
history and was very important in the
Middle Ages so I think it really needs
to be reflected in in fantasy and
particularly in a world where real magic
exists and we get that I was talking
about it earlier with the dragons and
the witches and all that but you know
consider that I mean we have a society
now where some people are very religious
some people were basically secular and
agnostic or atheist or even if they do
follow religion it's they don't really
guide their actions by it it's sort of
paying lip service to it but imagine
what the effect would be on religion
today on the world today if any of our
religions actually could perform
miracles imagine if there was someone
going around raising the dead or walking
on water or multiplying the fishes and
and the bread you know everybody would
follow that religion it would be on
television you would be interviewing
them and not me you know and we wouldn't
have any hunger anymore because we had
all the bread and fish we want and you
know it would change me well the fantasy
many fantasies out there have real magic
and they have real magic in some of them
a lot of powerful magic and then you
wonder why why they have multiple
religions then because if people can
actually do this kind of stuff I think
everybody would follow them now in my
world the religion is there but it's
it's more like the real world people
believe people think that certain things
are happening but the gods don't
actually turn up and the miracles are
unreliable and we don't quite know how
everything works we think there may be
agency supernatural agencies at work but
meanwhile there are various contesting
religions with their belief systems
Pantheon's that are struggling for
supremacy you've lived here in Santa Fe
since 1979 right but have things changed
for you recently as the profile of the
show and the books has raised and your
faces in magazines actually yes things
have changed a lot from me and in Perley
in the last four or five years I mean
I've always been a successful writer
I've had a excellent career since I sold
my first story in 71 I won awards early
on I was able to support myself as a
full-time writer since 1979 I made
pretty good money with these books I
started hitting the bestseller lists
with Clash of Kings the second one was
the first book of mine hit the
bestseller was since then each one has
done better so I've always been a
successful writer but what the show has
done is made me a celebrity writer and
that's different that's I had not
anticipated that and I guess I have now
reached a point where I am recognized
everywhere I go I can't go to a go
through an airport without stopping for
five photographs and signing people's
napkins and and you know occasionally
what I'm actually as the books in
restaurants and going to the movies
anywhere I'm I'm known I don't know now
there's good things that people come up
to me you're very nice they're they're
great they you know but sometimes it
gets a little tiring just because
there's so many of them I just keep
telling myself only forever this is my
15 minutes of fame right and you know
five years from now there'll be some
other show on television and Game of
Thrones will will be thought of
hopefully fondly as like NYPD Blue or
Hill Street Blues or or you know one of
the the great shows in television
history but it won't be on and there'll
be some new hot thing that everybody
will be all excited about and I can sort
of go back to being just a writer and
not a celebrity you create so many
characters we have a hard time keeping
track of them sometimes how do you do it
I mean do you have a wall where you've
tacked
pictures or note cards or is your mind
just I do have I do have note cards and
well not note cards but I have computer
files
I have genealogies and charts and things
like that and I have some pieces of
paper on which I've scrolled a few
things but less than you would think
most of it is is my mind I often say
that it's it's probably some strange
sort of mental illness or something that
I've I'm using the the synapses in my
brain that most people use for
remembering real people to remember all
these characters it's like I meet real
people and I forget their names two
minutes after I meet them it's in one
ear and out the other you know I wish
everybody went through life with
nametags all the time I would probably
be much better
my mind is a sieve as far as remembering
real people but I can remember these
these characters that I introduced for
one scene ten years ago in book two or
something like that and you know who
they are and what they look like and
that's stuck in my brain so that that
surely is a sign that I'm deranged but
hopefully it's a good sort of
derangement that allows me to write
these books